The humble pineapple is most often seen today
either sitting proudly in the centre of an
uncomfortably well stocked fruit bowl or being
used as the home of a lovable talking sponge.
However, between the 16th and 18th centuries,
pineapples were so expensive and rare that
they were often displayed like fine works
of art.
Converting exactly how much a whole pineapple
cost back in the 16th, 17th and 18th centuries
to modern day dollars is almost impossible
to do with any real accuracy.
That said, the general ballpark estimates
tend to ring in at around five to ten thousand
dollars per pineapple, depending on such things
as the quality of the fruit and season.
So how did this particular piece of fruit
come to be so valuable?
After the pineapple was first encountered
by Europeans on the island of Guadeloupe during
Christopher Columbus’ second trip to the
Caribbean in November of 1493, efforts were
quickly set in motion to find a way of reliably
producing the fruit back in Europe.
(The fruit itself is indigenous to South America
and had been cultivated there for centuries
prior to its “discovery” by Columbus.)
Despite sinking vast sums of money into the
problem, European royalty, who positively
adored the fruit for its natural sweetness
(sugar and sugary items being in short supply),
for centuries after its “discovery” the
only real way to obtain a pineapple was to
pay to have one directly imported, which was
no cheap affair.
Many transport ships of the age were too slow
and conditions too hot aboard the vessels
to keep whole pineapples from rotting during
the journey.
So to get a whole pineapple fruit safely from
the plant to one’s table in Europe took
the fastest ships and most favorable weather
conditions.
As a result, virtually the only people who
could afford to purchase a whole pineapple,
let alone eat one while it was perfectly ripe,
were royalty or the ridiculously wealthy.
The first step to allowing the rich, instead
of just the super rich, a chance to own or
even look at a pineapple wouldn’t come for
another two centuries after its “discovery”,
when the Dutch were able to begin successfully
cultivating the fruit in the very late 1600s.
Exactly who first managed to grow a pineapple
in a non-tropical climate isn’t known for
sure, though a woman named Agnes Block is
generally credited as being the earliest to
do so around 1687.
While earlier accounts of fruit producing
pineapple plants in Europe do exist, whether
or not these plants were cultivated in Europe
or simply transferred to the continent as
juveniles isn’t clear.
More important than Block in the pineapple
saga, however, was Dutch cloth merchant, Pieter
de la Court, who is often cited as the individual
who devised the most efficient (at the time)
method of growing pineapples in a non-tropical
climate.
His method was mostly comprised of utilising
hotrooms that were kept consistently warm
and humid.
These had to be carefully designed in order
to vent the smoke and hot fumes out of the
structure, while keeping the weather inside,
as well as the soil temperature, within very
specific ranges.
Accidentally burning down one’s pineapple
hotroom or killing the plants with smoke was
a very common thing in the early going.
After news of Court’s ability to grow pineapples
and other exotic plants and fruits year round
reached England, many nobles sent their gardeners
to the Netherlands to learn his techniques
first hand at considerable expense.
If you’re curious about why the Dutch had
such a stranglehold on Pineapple production,
it’s largely because the Dutch West India
Company enjoyed an almost total monopoly on
trade in the Caribbean at the time, allowing
wealthy Dutch citizens to import numerous
pineapple plants to experiment with, despite
the expense.
As you can probably imagine from the many
stereotypes that exist about British weather,
growing pineapples in England proved to be
rather difficult and it’s noted that only
exceptionally skilled or vastly wealthy gardeners
were capable of such a feat.
A man called John Rose is often mistakenly
attributed with growing the first pineapple
in England because of the existence of a painting
commissioned by Charles II in 1675 in which
he’s clearly shown presenting the king with
a ripe pineapple.
As it turns out, the pineapple seen in that
painting, which was based on a real encounter
the King had, was imported from the Bahamas
and ripened in England by Rose.
As for the real first pineapple grown on English
soil, that didn’t exist until around 1714-1716
when a Dutchman called Henry Telende was able
to grow one for his employer, Matthew Decker,
who subsequently had a painting commissioned
in 1720 to celebrate the not unimpressive
achievement.
Telende’s method of growing pineapples was
quite involved, managing to maintain the perfect
soil temperature via a specially designed
hothouse containing tan pits lined with pebbles
inside.
On top of the pebbles, he placed manure, then
on top of that sat tanners’ bark (oak bark
soaked in water).
Finally, the pot containing the pineapple
plant was placed in that.
Manure by itself created too much heat in
the early going, but the tanners’ bark helped
regulate that and provide a more even heat
over time, keeping a steady soil temperature
within the very specific range needed for
growing pineapple plants.
Even after growing pineapples on English soil
became a possibility, getting hold of one
was still so costly that many nobles didn’t
eat them, opting instead to simply display
them around their homes as one would a precious
ornament or carry them around at parties.
Those who weren’t quite as affluent could
also rent a pineapple for a few hours at a
time.
This pineapple would be passed around from
renter to renter for their respective parties
over the course of several days until finally
being sold to the individual who could actually
have the right to eat it.
Because of this, even among those who’d
handled pineapples, very few ever actually
experienced what it was like to eat a pineapple.
Due to the natural sweetness of the pineapple,
which was described as being akin to “Wine,
Rosewater and Sugar” all mixed together,
the fruit was seen as nothing short of a delicacy
by the notoriously sweet-toothed English elite
living in a time when refined sugar was a
very expensive commodity.
Charles II in particular was said to love
pineapple, partly due to its sweetness and
partly due to him being amused by the fact
the fruit looked like it was wearing a tiny
crown; as a result, Charles II often referred
to the fruit as the “King-pine”.
A final reason the pineapple was so popular,
at least with artists, was its unconventional,
striking appearance.
As 16th century Spanish historian Gonzalo
Fernandez de Oviedo y Valdes stated, “I
do not suppose that there is in the whole
world any other of so exquisite and lovely
appearances…
My pen and my words cannot depict such exceptional
qualities, nor appropriately blazon this fruit
so as to particularize the case fully and
satisfactorily without the brush or the sketch.”
Dunmore_PineappleIn fact, after the pineapple’s
introduction to England, it became a prominent
feature of art and architecture of the period,
such as Scotland’s now famous Dunmore Pineapple
(pictured right), commissioned in 1761 by
the Earl of Dunmore.
So the next time you order a pizza and see
that they casually put pineapple on it when
you clearly told them not to (because who
on Earth would want to sully delectable pizza
with a sweet fruit?
;-)), remember that three centuries ago, even
just having said fruit, let alone discarding
bits of it off your main dish, would have
been the ultimate sign of wealth and excess.
Today, you might have heard of the tradition
of presenting someone with a pineapple as
a housewarming present.
This tradition goes back to the time described
in the preceding article when presenting such
a gift was seen as a magnificent gesture.